il est 18h15 vous écoutez la première et
vous avez bien raison l lundi politique
gagne le dantec
ils sont assez rares les socialistes à
être restée macro nist alors qu'erica
barèges s'est clairement positionné dans
l'opposition au présent la république et
que le président de la cinor gérald
maillot à lui au contraire quitté le ps
pour se mettre en marche le maire de
saint-denis continuer à jouer les
équilibristes entre un parti qui se
cherche encore ehning et un président
qui s'affiche de plus en plus à droite
très critique vis-à-vis du président de
région qui par ailleurs lui aussi de
plus en plus macro compatibles notre
invité affiche avec fierté les résultats
dans sa commune avec toujours en avant
les questions liées à l'éducation et à
la jeunesse nous verrons avec lui ce
qu'il en est également du transport du
logement d'emploi la sécurité nous
demanderons aussi comment il vit cette
polémique qui n'en finit pas avec des
syndicats de policiers mécontents
gilbert annette maire de saint-denis
également conseiller régional est
l'invité de lundi politique sur la
première émission que vous pouvez suivre
en vidéo sur notre site internet
j'y parlais bonsoir oui bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans
l'actualité il ya donc cette polémique
resurgit que l'on croyait un peu éteinte
avec certains syndicats de la police
nationale ce week-end sur le site
internet radar 9 7 4 un internaute
traite les policiers deux chiens
commentaire d'une photo de contrôle qui
se passait vraiment rachel leclerc
indignation des syndicats de police on
les comprend et le syndicat alliance
dénoncent une banalisation des attaques
et des insultes à l'encontre des forces
de l'ordre y compris dit un représentant
d'alliance de l'appart de premier
magistrat d'une grande commune on
suppose que c'est de vous dont il s'agit
rappelle que vous aviez déjà eu un souci
avec les syndicats de policiers quelques
et quelques mois suite à des propos vous
avez tenu que quelques ailes rapport
vous avez aujourd'hui avec la police
nationale d'abord moi je respecte la
police et bien sûr les policiers qui
font un métier difficile
je condamne ces insultes ses propos je
me suis déjà expliqué je crois que si
sony a aujourd'hui ce taux de
délinquance c'est à dire le plus faible
taux des villes françaises de 150000
habitants des 20 villes françaises
quarante sept pour milan c'est un chiffe
de qualité nous le devons notamment
grâce au travail de la police dont 3
j'ai levé la menace qu'est ce que les
syndicats de police en contre vous non
ils ont on a interprété en assorti de
deux phrases que j'ai prononcé que bien
sûr je revendique mais qui sont sortis
de leur contexte parler du manque
d'effectif des policiers la nuit et du
fait que nous avons été amenés à à
financer des médiateurs de nuit dont je
me suis expliqué j'étais reçu tout à
fait normalement par le directeur de la
sécurité publique monsieur le monde tu
m'a tout expliqué nous tout est rentré
dans l'ordre il n'y a plus de polémique
moi je mets un point un point final à
ces polémiques moi je respecte la police
j'ai beaucoup de nous travaillons avec
les policiers tous les jours je vais
augmenter le parc de vidéosurveillance
je mets en place des mvp
non ce sont des des interprétations
sorti du contexte
j'ai dit dans le cadre notamment du
projet ambition moi je proposé aux
jeunes ambitionner d'être commissaire
voilà tout ça live et dépréciations plus
importantes et c'était pas c'était
malvenu basses considérations un
policier de base
sauf que moi j'ai un frère que j'aime
beaucoup qui a un grand syndicat lycée
qui a fini sa carrière comme sous
brigadier dont le fils est gardienne la
paix avec un master dont j'ai beaucoup
de respect dans ma famille même nous
sommes des militaires des policiers dans
tout ça est mal venu à un cheveu
je n'ai je met un point final parce que
je continue à travailler avec la police
pour les résultats et je condamne bien
sûr ceux qui qui malmènent qui insulte
les policiers les policiers mais pas que
les pompiers ceux qui interviennent avec
les ambulances etc
ils viennent secourir la population
aider la population et devrait être
respectée justement en dehors de cette
polémique
quels sont aujourd'hui les difficultés
que vous pouvez rencontrer sur saint
denis en termes de sécurité on parle de
deux rodéos on parle vous disiez de 2 x
2 d'intervention de policiers qui sont
caillassés ou de pompiers comment est ce
que en tant que maire pouvait intervenir
là dessus bah écoutez d'abord moi je
je suis en train de recruter ce qu'on
appelle les agents surveillants de
l'espace public des asvp genre 18,2 pour
par secteur du neuf secteurs qui vont
avoir en charge tout au long de la
journée de veiller au respect de
l'espace week d'abord du stationnement
mais de l'environnement également
puisque nous veillons à la propreté pour
nous la propreté dans la ville c'est
important donc ces personnes là pourront
verbaliser les contrevenants y compris
les bailleurs sociaux qui laisse voilà
sur des terrains leur appartenant
des encombrants des choses comme ça et
ils vont veiller à une nouvelle
nuisances qui est la nuisance sonore le
bruit un an
il ya un manque de respect il ya
beaucoup donc nous avons renforcé ce
corps donc nous dépensons de l'argent
nous avons bien sûr toute une politique
de prévention de la délinquance avec les
associations nous travaillons
avec aussi cette vidéo surveillance pour
régulariser donc nous faisons un effort
mais je répète les chiffres des cinq
premiers mois
c'est important et bien la délinquance
est en baisse sur sani entre janvier et
mai sur l'année 2010 est de -23%
c'est important sur le chiffre 2010 est
qu'ils étaient en baisse de 8% dont je
veux pas construction et d'incivilités
qu'on aura sans doute non il ya des
affiliés il ya de la délinquance bien
sûr et puis il ya des faits cruel vous
savez sont les faits de violence intra
muros extra qui font partie mais qui
sont des faits scandaleux dramatique
mais qui aurait eu heureusement ne sont
pas nombreux quand on parle de la
délinquance on globalise l'ensemble des
actes de délinquance des délits
notamment
et l'on voit que le nombre de délits
hassani est nettement inférieur de celui
de dijon de clermont ferrand de l'île
dont voilà il ya de la délinquance on
travaille on travaille beaucoup
ah mais vous savez bien qu'il ya deux
actions et à la répression et à la
prévention et la prévention c'est lié à
l'éducation d'un enfant est un gros
travail dans les écoles autour de
l'éducation déjà là je voulais venir
justement ce que lutter contre
l'insécurité c'est d'abord effectivement
probablement d'abord lutté pour
l'éducation pour l'emploi pour
l'épanouissement des jeunes et des moins
jeunes vaste programme évidemment dans
votre politique municipale avant de
détailler certains points je vois bien
faire votre vision d'ensemble du
problème en tant que maire quels sont
les objectifs que vous pouvez vous fixé
finalement pour l'épanouissement de ces
jeunes sur quoi est ce que vous avez la
main bah écoutez d'abord nous
accompagnons l'éducation nationale 1 qui
lance par exemple le programme
dédoublement des cpdc dont nous nous
avons été tout de suite volontaires et
nous avons même anticipé on en fait plus
donc nous tout dans les écoles ce qu'on
appelle l'éducation prioritaire un redd
+ cerep
nous allons avoir des cp à 12 et des ce1
12 donc ça c'est fantastique puisque le
rectorat mais des enseignants à un
enseignant pour douze élèves avaient
plus efficace et ça va aider à l'échec
soeur donc nous nous équipons nous
faisons les classes aux équipes aux et
nous livrons à l'éducation et à nous
faisons à notre grand programme qui est
de transformer nos écoles en école nue
mais
rick non nous sommes en train de faire
toutes les écoles primaires de 7 44
écoles en 2019 au rô le label école
numérique avec bien sûr des réseaux il
faut brancher et ensuite il faut des
tableaux numériques des tablettes tout
un équipement numérique et ensuite
l'éducation nationale forment les
enseignants à la pédagogie du numérique
donc ça c'est l'aspect accompagnement en
éducation nationale mais nous à côté de
ça nous avons sans doute un des plus
ambitieux programme d'accompagnement
dans les activités périscolaires vous le
savez nous avons eu d'abord dès le
départ un plan anglais à grande section
maternelle cp cea nous offrons écoutez
bien 200 intervenants d'anglais quand la
région j'avais une tactique qui ont lieu
sur le plan de la région parce que parce
qu'il fallait l'être parce que quand le
président de la région annonce en 2015 à
la mare à citrons qu'il va lancer un
grand plan ambitieux que c'est
nécessaire d'apprendre l'anglais aux
jeunes réunionnais parce que c'est
qu'une nécessité mondiale et bien et
qu'il n'engage que 20 assistants de
langues
alors que saint denis la commune de
saigner en engager 200 c'est dire que
son plan est limité mode s ridicule même
par arriver améliorée ils arrêtent le
plan mais c'est catastrophique soit
l'anglais est vraiment nécessaire aux
jeunes réunionnais moi je crois eh bien
il faut il faut pas renoncer il faut pas
jeter ce plan abandonner nos enfants moi
je continue et ça fait 10 ans est ce que
vous pouvez mesurer le résultat de ce
que vous faites
alors ce plan anglais parce que voilà
c'est bien de mettre des moyens mais est
ce qu'à un moment on peut mesurer ce que
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne pas leur jeu
au sol et les jeunes dionysiens devienne
bilingue
voilà ils sont en train ça fait dix ans
nous allons fêter ses 10 ans la mercredi
et jeudi à un jeune
rendez vous notamment aux parents aux
enseignants à la cité des arts puisque
nous rassemblons beaucoup d'ateliers et
nous présente fonctionne rendu la vue du
projet éducatif global voilà roger du
côté villa dont l'anglais le savoir
parler anglais et est un des
une des actions importantes puisque nous
l'avons généralisée alors effectivement
la difficulté c'est d'évaluer l'impact
puisque ensuite ce que nous faisons est
repris par l'éducation nationale ces
élèves qui ont fait anglais en cp en ca
ils sont repris en c2 puisqu'aujourd'hui
vous le savez l'éducation nationale a
généralisé à anticiper l'apprentissage
de l'anglais à mon époque et à la vote
sans doute on faisait l'anglais en 6e
aujourd'hui on commenceront ce2 cm1 sont
donc s'est repris mais l'objectif c'est
qu'à 18 20 ans les enfants parlent
anglais
il passe notamment un examen qui permet
d'étudier dans des universités anglaises
qui le taux folle a donc nous nous
voulons qu'un grand nom le plus grand
nombre possible et que demain et bien
les réunionnais
par l'anglais de façon à pouvoir mieux
se battre dans le cas de la
mondialisation de l'économie d'un cadre
du développement touristique
vous avez été très critique vis-à-vis du
plan anglais de la région vous avez été
également très critique sur le l'absence
de résultats dans la lutte contre
l'illettrisme
mais à votre niveau à la saint denis
qu'est-ce que alors certes les enfants
apprennent l'anglais mais le taux de
jeunes illettrés lui ne baisse pas
quelle claque est ce que vous ne faites
pas ou est ce que nous nous orientons
donc nous faisons nous nous savons que
il ya l'illettrisme y à il ya deux
sources ya d'abord les anciens qui ne
sont pas allés à l'école puisque le taux
d'illettrisme dans les 60 65 ans et de
près de 40% 39% ça c'est le résultat du
passé mais aujourd'hui la catastrophe
c'est que les enfants de la réunion qui
sortent du système scolaire 2000 sont
considérés comme il est trés cinq ans
après donc il faut lutter et c'est pour
ça que nous nous faisons évidemment ce
ce
ce plan éducatif pour mettre la
meilleure éducation possible possible
dès la maternelle cp améliorer la
performance à l'école pour que ses
enfants quand il quitte à 18 ou 16 ans
ne devienne pas quatre ans ou 5 un prêt
d illettrés et ce travail là ce sont les
activités périscolaires
nous avons généralisé le yoga l'école
savoir nager le théâtre la musique
beaucoup d'activités les échecs pour
apprendre à se concentrer dont nous
apportons tout un un complément éducatif
pour que l'enfant soit bien qu'il étudie
bien le suivi des devoirs pour que
l'échec scolaire soient réduits mais ça
évidemment la ville intervient en
complément l'éducation nationale c'est
d'abord la tâche de l'éducation
nationale et des parents à les parents
sont les premiers éducateurs des enfants
et nous nous apportons ce qu'aucune
commune fait aucune ville fait en france
donc moi je suis très fier parce que
pourquoi je vais vous dire moi j'ai plus
qu'une conviction j'ai la foi dans
l'éducation c'est moi même j'ai eu la
chance de bénéficier d'une bonne
éducation puisque j'ai quitté mes
parents à 12 ans je suis allé en
métropole et donc je sais que c'est ça
l'essentiel
c'est l'éducation et il faut pour la
réunion y aura pas d'avenir à la réunion
tout le reste est inutile ne sert à rien
si on réussit pas les ducs sur
l'éducation est fondamentale
il n'y a pas de développement économique
sans des acteurs économiques développés
puisque c'est d'abord une compétition
d'hommes et de femmes l'économie et si
vous n'avez pas des acteurs développer
instruit et cultivé capable de sentir
les choses de mener à bien des projets
il y aura pas d block pré-collecte donc
l'éducation c'est essentiel c'est
primordial et nous nous mettons alors
vous mettez un paquet notamment sur tout
ce qui activités périscolaires on était
sur une semaine de cinq jours les
parents ont voté ils veulent retourner à
la semaine de 4 jours vous regretter un
peu parce que vous étiez favorable au
système précis mais je n'étais pas en
tant que spécialistes parce que j'ai vu
et j'ai vu que ce qu'on appelait les
chronobiologistes les médecins qui
étudie la capacité de concentration des
enfants là la meilleure période d'étude
pour les enfants considéré qu'
aujourd'hui en france les journées
d'école sont trop longs et il ya trop de
vacances est à l'image de ce qui se fait
en finlande au danemark dans les pays du
nord
des bons résultats il considère qu'il
faut raccourcir la journée et faire plus
de journée bon les parents décidèrent
autrement 80% moi j'ai mon idée mais je
suis aussi un démocrate et je me suis
plié aux voeux des parents qui ont voté
à 80 % pour la semaine de quatre jours
donc nous allons faire ce nous allons
nous organiser pour faire la semaine de
4 jours ce qui va mettre en cause les
activités en fin de journée là vers 4h
4h30 donc est le vois de supprimer elles
vont être supprimés nous allons essayer
de les remplacer dans la pause
méridienne en partie et nous travaillons
puisque le ministre de l'éducation a
donné à un moyen supplémentaire pour
organiser des activités le mercredi donc
nous sommes en train d'ouvrir la
subvention pour ça reste peu par rapport
au coût 1 euro de l'heure par un
français peut donc nous sommes en train
de travailler nos services pour voir
qu'est ce que nous pourrons faire de
plus avec ce crédit parce que pour nous
les activités périscolaires notamment
les arts la musique le théâtre sont
indispensables à l'épanouissement des
ans
on le sait le gouvernement a aussi opté
pour moins d'emplois aidés ou en tout
cas pour une réforme des employés qui va
aboutir forcément à la fin à moins
d'employés puisqu'il faut le financement
des collectivités et plus en plus
important ça veut dire pour vous -
l'animateur mois l'assistante maternelle
nous avons donnent ça vous y revenez
vous à l'éducation dans les écoles dans
les écoles nous avions en gros si 150
contrats aidés nous n'aurons à la
rentrée que 450 pec 1 puisque les c8
emploi compétences ouais mais qui sont
moins financés à 50 % quand les eaux
traitées à 80 de ces demandes de la part
de la commune aux efforts budgétaires
supplémentaires surtout dans un contexte
où l'état limitent la progression de nos
dépenses à plus 1,2 dont c'est quand
même la quadrature du cercle nous bateau
avec deux directions générales et nous
sommes en train d'essayer dans les
arbitrages ils sont très difficiles sont
douloureuses à l'east river sentir
passer le côté nous allons supprimer un
certain nombre d'actions réduire en tous
les cas les galas dans les ont pas nous
sommes en train de travailler sur tout
tout ce qui est un petit peu les grandes
festivités à nous avons diminué de 25%
les
graulhet grande fête les budgets du 14
juillet du 20 décembre ont été diminués
parce que nous n'avons pas les moyens de
faire ce que nous faisions donc nous
passons de 4 millions à 3 millions donc
c'est un million - sommes en train de
travailler sur pas beaucoup de
dispositifs les heures supplémentaires
bien sûr nous avons supprimé
je lui ai déjà dit les voitures de
fonction à gagner de l'argent de ce
primo voilà un certain nombre de
dépenses nous réduisons les un certain
nombre de frais pour pouvoir maintenir
l'essentiel et l'essentiel c'est
l'éducation c'est bien sûr vous allez
pouvoir maintenir le même niveau en
termes d'éducation en termes d'éducation
nous l'espérons pour aujourd'hui mais
difficile parce que nous avons un
dispositif que nous avons pas bien
utilisés sont les services civiques nous
avions une centaine de service civique
je pense que nous avons mal appréhendé
ce dispositif on la considère un peu
comme un emploi et des jeunes
or c'est autre chose c'est un engagement
donc on veut leur donner du sens à
rajouter 4 également être pas cher
certains penser ça mais je pense que non
ce sont des jeunes qui s'engagent à main
tant qu'ils veulent servir leur
collectivité donc nous allons leur
apporter un encadrement créer un esprit
de promotion les accompagner avec des
aides complémentaires en termes de 2
je dirais gratuité dans les transports
cantine scolaire gratuite pour les
mobiliser aussi et puis leur apporter un
complément jeudi sur la propre formation
mais on va utiliser on espère 300
service civique au lieu de 100 à
condition de pouvoir les capter pour
l'instant nous avons eu du mal à engager
service public donc on va entreprendre
une campagne de recrutement des services
civiques en en améliorant le dispositif
gibert net au delà de l'éducation des
jeunes moins jeunes d'ailleurs ont
besoin de d'activités de loisirs de
culture n'a pas le sentiment que la
ville de saint-louis qu'un peu endormi
en dehors de certains quartiers le soir
c'est un peu c'est un peu mort est-ce
que vous avez la même que les dionysiens
ont accès à de la culture l'activité
artistique haaby sport dans tous les
quartiers et les moments dans tous les
cas en matière de sport la ville sport
très bien le long de l'année de nombreux
titres reçoit régulièrement j'ai ensuite
les volleyeurs fille garçon qui sont
championnes de la réunion nous avons une
équipe unss qui est championne de france
en danse du collège des mascareignes
nous avons de nombreux lauréats
nationaux et internationaux le sport va
très bien soignés dans cette diversité
alors en matière artistique culturel
donc nous avons un outil qui est quand
même très dynamique
c'est la cité des arts où il ya une
animation c'est vrai que dans la ville
en terme d'animation nocturne
nous étions un peu au ralenti et les
choses s'améliorent elles vont
s'améliorer sensiblement puisque le
multiplexe cinéma par exemple a démarré
le mois prochain mois de juillet donc
les c'est un projet pour lequel nous
sommes battus donc deux ont un
multiplexe à l'entrée de sani un certain
nombre de projets d'animation nocturne
sur le centre ville vont connaître un
développement 1 je parle delà de ce
qu'on appelle communément la villa du
général qui redémarre sur le front de
mer là où il y avait les récréateurs
nous sommes entrain d'attribuer cet
équipement sera brasseur alors je
préfère attendre encore parce que le
projet était arrêtée mais je voudrais
rencontrer le promoteur pour bien
mesurer mais s'est radouci avant qu'un
indice c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne très bien à saint pierre 1
autour de la bière du vin en fassiez
c'est au tour de sam est quelque chose
de qualité et et il ya un projet autour
des 3 brasseurs autour d'une rom rien
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
faisait défaut à la réunion avec de la
gastronomie régionale donc un beau
projet mais là il fallait un promoteur
qui sont capables de relever le défi
parce qu'il ya un million et demi de
travaux avant de commencer à exploiter
donc nous sommes en train de mettre la
dernière main dont ceni va se salit mais
davantage vous avez vu le quartier de la
cathédrale qui est un quartier qui
fonctionne on est en train de démarrer
dont sony n'est plus que tu es sénia 5
10 ans mais il ya encore de la marge et
nous travaillons là-dessus avec les
professionnels et les choses avancent
parce que ce que nous voulons c'est à la
fois de l'animation mais de la sécurité
un mot de la couenne or on sait que
l'infrastructure a tracé quelques
difficultés financières on en est où là
bah écoute et ce avec la cua nord c
un équipement qui dépend de la cinor
mais je sais qu'ils sont toujours du mal
à trouver la bonne vitesse de croisière
qui qui permet de bad et dégager des
marges gagner de l'argent c'est un outil
il faut l'exploiter au mieux donc faut
que la formule restauration il faut
remplir feu des centres et avec un tarif
qui est un tarif évidemment bon marché
puisque nos tarifs il est trois fois
moins cher que le tarif du privé mais
pour l'instant je sais que l'équilibré
difficile donc il faut bel équilibre
sont les acteurs économiques qui
prennent l'outil donc c'est à eux a
inventé les voies publiques ont leur mot
à dire dans le choix de l'acteur puisse
y à un appel à projet mais ensuite quand
celui qui a gagné l'appel à projets bas
il lui appartient de trouver les
recettes pour faire fonctionner qui
libre et et vous avez raison de dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'équilibré toujours pas
trouvé donc il faut continuer la
conquête
bah oui c'est pas c'est pas rassurant
qu'un bel outil comme ça n'arrive pas à
être exploité avec des marges et gagner
donc il faut inventer les formules là on
est dans le domaine privé de la
compétition à travers tous les acteurs
économiques voilà dans la restauration
dans l'animation nocturne donc il faut
que les responsables soient plus
inventifs et arrive à équilibrer à
gagner de l'argent le chômage en légère
baisse
on va dire cette dernière année ce que
si on regarde sur les sur les sur les
dix dernières années en légère baisse à
la réunion malgré tout il reste très
élevé 23 % à 23 %
ça veut dire des perspectives compliqué
pour les jeunes même ceux qui grâce au
système éducatif peuvent en sortir
diplômée et armés ça reste très
compliquée qu est ce que vous dites aux
jeunes est ce que on a fait des missions
ya pas très longtemps sur l'emploi dans
le cadre du débat du mardi est en gros
ce qu'il en sortait s'est payé une
partie des jeunes qui doivent partir
doivent aller chercher du travail en
métropole alors il ya de choix est ce
que vous diriez ça aussi où est ce que
vous êtes confiant dans la possibilité
pour la réunion pour saint-denis
d'offrir demande de l'emploi oui il ya
deux choses d'abord le chômage est grave
c'est le problème numéro un à rayons
depuis très longtemps et on n'avait pas
sorti
continue à se battre sauf que le chômage
globalement il était à 30% et quelques
années il a 23 sait trop quand il est en
métropole autour de neuf donc nous nous
sommes sans doute une des régions les
plus sinistrées c'est un cauchemar et je
regrette que le gouvernement ne prennent
pas la mesure de sa star qui est pas des
dispositifs particuliers que la réforme
des contrats aidés n'ait pas été
appliquée avec plus de souplesse à la
réunion parce que nous sommes sinistrés
et que en même temps ils sont dans les
chiffres
parce que en métropole qu'est la
différence quand vous êtes chômeur dans
le 93 les dans le 92 les dans le 75 vous
prenez le rer etc nous c'est pas pareil
faut partir faut prendre l'avion donc
notre situation est très compliquée et
hélas réseau bien sûr il ya il ya un
développement économique aurait souvent
notre croissance est supérieure la
croissance en maître employant 3 % quand
la basse et un an et demi donc on avance
sauf que il y a une démographie ya une
arrivée de jeunes proportionnellement
beaucoup plus nombreuses à la réunion
qu'en métropole mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que ça ni quand le chômage est à
23% la réunion le chômage est assainie à
19%
donc c'est beaucoup mieux que dans les
autres communes de lannion mais ça nous
a bien ça n'est pas bien et nous
travaillons bien sûr mais c'est pas moi
qui qui qui qui est aux jeunes qu'il
faut pas partir au contraire moi même je
suis parti et dans ma famille
pratiquement tout le monde est parti
certains sont revenus d'autres son essai
dont la réunion avec ces jeunes ne peut
pas offrir à tous les jeunes en emploi
correct un bon emploi la réunion donc
une partie est appelée à partir mais il
faut partir dans de bonnes conditions au
d'ailleurs bien armés avec des
qualifications et avec une ambition
parce que haye a pas que la france il ya
le bon et faut se former est allé
chercher le bon emploi donc ça c'est
normal mais il faut aussi que les jeunes
et que le système prépare les jeunes aux
emplois disponibles parce que le
problème c'est que des entreprises
disent aussi ne pas trouver localement
la main d'oeuvre dont elle a besoin
quand elle a besoin donc là il ya une
forme de décalage entre la formation
l'appareil de formation et les besoins
des entreprises donc là je crois qu'un
vrai chant il faut
mieux rapprocher à la fois le monde
économique et l'appareil de formation
pour ajuster la formation besoins des
entreprises il y encore trop d'emplois
qui échappe aux jeunes demandeurs
d'emploi lario parce qu'ils ne sont pas
ils correspondent pas au profil des
enfants donc là ya un effort à faire
mais vraisemblablement et moi bien sûr
je je je le sais je
je considère que c'est normal une partie
de notre jeunesse devra partir parce
qu'elle n'aura pas d'emplois ici un mot
de la situation du transport alors ça
fait partie des attributions plutôt des
intercommunalités aujourd'hui voire de
la région malgré tout en tant que maire
de saint denis vous avez votre mot à
dire on disait parce que vous êtes
arrivé très en avance par peur des
embouteillages et finalement ça veut
dire qu'il y en a pas mais c'est un peu
exceptionnel
aujourd'hui ça circule bien mais ce
n'est pas tous les jours comme ça on
sent qu'on arrive en fin d'année
peut-être caisse quand est ce qu'on va
pouvoir enfin circuler normalement dans
saint-denis ailleurs le projet de la
nouvelle entrée ouest les téléphériques
tout ça c'est dans les cartons ou est-ce
que ça commence à sentir chose je crois
que la situation s empire pour une
raison simple c'est que allard ayant
tous les ans on apporte 25 mille
voitures et cassany il y à tous les ans
15 km de voitures supplémentaires
aligner donc sur dix ans cela représente
150 km et voyez bien qu'on veut pas vous
verso bouleversé les réseaux de routes
donc expliqué film en mai 5 % seulement
des réunionnais utilisent les transports
en commun et c'est vraiment ce qu'ils
n'ont pas le choix
absolument donc il faut améliorer rendre
attractif qu'est ce que nous faisons
nous nous voulons changer la mentalité
des jeunes comme en en faisant le
transport en commun gratuit dès 18 ans
ça coûte cher
et là nous sommes nous avons fait 18
jusqu'à 11 ans et cette année à la
rentrée nous allons faire 9-10 ans et
l'année prochaine
huit sept six ans dont à saint denis
pour changer les mentalités pour
familiariser les jeunes avec le
transport commun que nous le rendons
gratuit pour tout le monde y est près de
12000 chaque jour de vous considérer
qu'il est fiable à il est fiable il peut
toujours être améliorés toujours des
embouteillages donc nous nous savons que
pour le rendre encore plus attractif
il faut faire des couards protéger ce
rappel le tcsp
ce n'est pas facile parce que
bah ça contrevient à d'autres etc mais
nous nous battons et nous nous affirmons
que la solution c'est le transport en
commun qu'il faut lutter contre le tout
voiture individuelle donc ça c'est la kz
ensuite c'est quoi bein c'est le
transport par câble téléphérique et vous
le savez que je salue gérald maillot qui
se bat à qui sera méprisée
le président la cinor qui qui va sortir
le premier téléphérique un des plus
grands de france deux kilomètres et demi
cinq stations entre bois de nèfles au
chaudron ça prend corps il ya des
difficultés à être toujours ici et là ça
coince
mais je connais son énergie sa volonté
je l'accompagnent bien sûr puisque cm
s'est assaini c'est pour ça n'est donc
la première ligne probablement sera
livrée fin 2010 love sera livré et
ensuite suivra une année après ou deux
ans la ligne montagne belles pierres et
d'autres lignes dont le transport
bien sûr tu es fric mais il n'ya pas que
ça y est la nouvelle au showest ce sera
la variable et la croix parce que on
entendu didier robert dire bah voilà la
nouvelle route du littoral elle va
arriver à saint denis en même temps que
de nouvelles entrées la première
ménagers oui la première partie de la
nouvelle entrée ouais c'est à dire entre
le rond-point devant la caserne et la
rue de paris ça s'est engagée c'est sous
maîtrise ouvrage de la région et c'est
parti ensuite le grand projet du
souterrain et ses mouvements l'étude
dans les études se font rien il ya une
convention avec l'état la région et la
mairie de saint denis mais une partie du
financement dépend du plan européen 2026
donc il ya quand même
nous nous voulons le faire ils ont ça
remplit j'aiderai les conditions pour
être éligible mais ce n'est pas fait
mais nous nous allons nous battre pour
ça et d'autres projets comme intermède
musical vous avez choisi gilbert annette
batarsité de données
apa - six mots l'histoire totti est un
bien mal au bas
- nation bas nous faut un bâtard totti
kamal ben oui
[Musique]
date est situé cet athée si tu mets ton
blanc cité
[Musique]
j'espère que d'année nous excusera de
consentir l'inconnu dans l'occasion de
l'écouter à à d'autres moments sur sur
notre antenne gilbert annette vous avez
choisi batarsité d'un miroir ou pourquoi
j'aime beaucoup bien sûr des wôrô au
cham surtout le sens le contenu les
messages et parce que j'adhère bien sûr
à cette vision de la réunion métis à ce
message antiraciste et je crois qu'il
est d'actualité il faut le professer il
faut le défendre les actualités parce
que parce que il est menacé ici à la
réunion en europe en général dans le
monde à la réunion également un
contrairement à ce qu'on dit moi
j'entends ici et là des propos racistes
donc il faut qu'on soit vigilant faut
surtout qu'on apporte des réponses sans
c'est qu'on explique le le racisme ça
des fondements fondement intellectuel et
donc il faut l'antithèse il faut
combattre il faut tordre le cou avec des
arguments il s'agit pas de rejeter les
racistes il faut condamner se bat contre
le racisme contre la philosophie contre
l'idée du racisme contre les principes
et moi je vais vite autour de moi et je
mène ce combat et à la réunion il ya un
racisme anti malgache anti comoriens
anti mahorais anti vous l'entendez je
l'entends je suis arrivé je suis outrée
et je suis scandalisée et
je mets en garde ceux qui sont autour de
moi pour que je ne sois pas passifs ils
soient pas complice si vous voulez quand
ils entendent qu'ils osent contredire
qu'ils osent réagir parce qu'il ne faut
pas banaliser le racisme
on a le sentiment que en europe en ce
moment qu'on parle de lèpre nationaliste
ça vous inquiète ce qui se passe là bas
je suis très inquiet repak en europe
bien sûr mais dans le monde je pense que
la situation internationale s'est
dégradée en europe également avec ce qui
s'est passé bien entendu en italie mais
partout en hongrie en pologne
je vois comme tous les français saupin
monter le populisme et le national et
c'est nous moi je suis un militant anti
pop et antinationale chiens chats
sociale ijss je me bat pour des valeurs
universelles de tolérance de respect de
solidarité et bien sûr le populisme et
alain verte ça le le nationalisme et moi
je suis internationaliste et et je
souffre de ça mais je vois bien que nos
adversaires gagne du terrain que une
frange de la population de plus en plus
importante et est gagné par ses idées
donc c'est sans doute aussi le prix à
payer pour une forme d'échec de l'europe
l'europe ne pas relever n'a pas su faire
donc aujourd'hui il faut se reprendre il
faut trouver les réponses positives pour
ne pas désespérer des européens et par
dépit ce se réfugier dans le sectarisme
le rejet des autres nationalités c'est
un vrai danger
est ce que c'est la peur de ce populisme
ambiant qui a fait kamonia lacroix a pas
proposé d'accueillir ce bateau de
réfugiés
l'accord husky et rire méditerranée
et maniema conques a critiqué l'italie
pour pas l'avoir accueilli mais qui à
part composé d'amples accueillir sur sa
route entre entre la méditerranée et
l'espagne oui moi je suis déçu de la
frilosité du gouvernement français mais
je pense qu'elle est à l'image du peuple
français je pense qu emmanuel macron
matière mais il a tort fait ce que les
français ressentent ils sont très
frileux ils sont 100 replié il on porte
donc effectivement il s'agit pas de
faire n'importe quoi mais je trouve que
face à je dirais à cette catastrophe
assez à ces naufragés faut que le
sentiment humaniste l'humanité prennent
le dessus avant même la loi avant ses
calculs politiciens donc je pense qu'il
a mal fait contrairement aux
responsables socialistes espagnols qui a
eu la bonne démarche et j'ai été
agréablement surpris de l'entendre des
mots d'encouragement des espagnols qui
adhéraient plutôt à cette démarche
voilà je crois qu'il faut pas renoncer
il faut relever le gant il faut se
battre nous a toujours socialiste
oui j'ai adhéré en 1971 au congrès
d'epinay avec françois mitterrand dont
je suis société je suis un militant j'ai
consacré ma vie
est-ce qu'on peut être socialiste et
avoir soutenu macron comme vous l'avez
fait est ce qu'il n'ya pas un moment un
petit problème n'est pas un grand écart
oui ce n'est pas facile séoul avait
parlé d' équilibre c'est vrai parce que
moi j'ai soutenu macron dans un contexte
un qui était pour moi le risque soit du
front national que je rejeté la
république ainsi parce que pour moi
fillon s'était ultralibéral cité plus
haut qu'un contraste et la tva sociale
enfin une catastrophe ou même ce que
j'appelle la gauche protestataire de
mélenchon que je trouvais
dangereuse donc moi j'ai choisi le
projet qui me paraissait un projet de
réforme mais je constate aussi que ce
projet que j'ai soutenu présent j'ai
soutenu aujourd'hui vous en parle au
passé
non nous soutenez toujours oui je
soutiens tout en sachant que c'est de
plus en plus difficile que mon parti
évidemment à juste titre est très
critique pour ce début de mandat
j'aurais pu me mettre exclus du parti
on va soutenir les mac ou ouais il
appartenait à mon parti de faire ce qui
est bon mais je continue à être membre
du parti dans une position un peu en
retrait et et à penser que ces réformes
sont les réformes d'un premier temps
qu'elles sont nécessaires pour pouvoir
je dirais connaître une croissance et
ensuite engager la phase plus sociale on
je l'espère donc je pense et je la hais
j'approuve cette démarche qui commence
par donner des gages au monde économique
en espérant que la croissance sera au
rendez vous et qu'on pourra mieux
partager les fruits de la croissance
dont je pense que ce sont des efforts
nécessaires parce que je considère que
la france a vécu au dessus de ses moyens
en empruntant massivement que les
comptes étaient dégradées qu'il fallait
du courage pour rétablir l'équilibré des
comptes et ensuite à obtenir une
croissance économique supprimant la
france des moyens supprimés d impôt qui
pesait sur les entrepreneurs les plus
riches et demandé aux collectivités
comme la vôtre de se serrer la ceinture
vous trouvez ça normal
non je veux pape avoir cette lecture je
pense qu'il faut avoir un dispositif
fiscal notamment sur l'entreprise qui
soit équivalent à ce que font nos
concurrents voisins européens donc nous
sommes en compétition donc il faut pas
non plus être naïf ou angélique il faut
avoir une fiscalité qui fasse que nos
chefs d'entreprises n'aille pas en
allemagne ou en europe de l'est ce parce
que rester en france
ce n'est pas bien et a eu à y créer des
emplois ailleurs donc je pense que là
c'est dur mais on peut pas faire
autrement que de s'aligner sur nos
concurrents nos compétiteurs sinon on
perd des emplois nos entreprises se
délocalisent ailleurs
ce sont les français qui souffre donc je
pense que c'est une politique difficile
mais qu'on doit la mener
ce que je trouve parfois il y à des
gestes symboliques qui sont absents et
on n'explique pas assez et on s'engage
pas assez dans je dirais ce qu'on
prévoit pour la deuxième phase comment
va distribuer les fruits de la
croissance qui va en bénéficier
et moi je reste attentif bien sûr à la
solidarité
je souhaite que les français qui souffre
le plus les petits les cheveux et les
gens en difficulté ou encore le discours
ambiant du côté du gouvernement on a
plutôt l'impression que c'est pas pour
demain la redistribution enfin deux de
trop dette sociale ça risque de
continuer à être un peu compliqué le nom
oui bon c'est une lecture on parle
d'inefficacité des aides sociales dans
leur ensemble c'est à dire que le
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
dans une période qui était aussi une
période favorable où la croissance était
là que ces aides sociales n'ont pas
permis à ceux qui en bénéficiaient de
sortir de la précarité donc que l' on
rediscute pour avoir des aides sociales
puis efficaces qui permettent aux
français de quitter cette zone difficile
pourquoi pas encore faut-il voir
qu'est-ce qu'on va proposer et et en
quoi elles ne sont pas efficaces que le
gouvernement s'interroge sur
l'efficacité de l'argent public c'est
bien moi même en tant que responsable
d'une collectivité de l'art sans fumée
que moi j'ai 300 millions tous les jours
je m'interroge sur l'efficacité de nos
actions et je crois que c'est le devoir
de ceux qui utilisent l'argent public
bien se poser la question et ne pas
continuer à faire les choses uniquement
parce que ça se faisait en oubliant ça
se faisait dans un certain contexte que
le bond de change et qu'il faut adapter
le dispositif dont vous gardez votre
confiance pour l'instant dans le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe way de
jeu je garde ma confiance dans la
nécessité de faire des réformes même si
elles sont impopulaires et difficile je
pense qu'elle devrait toujours comme
jambe gauche va avancer
oui je pense et je veux
et je verrai dans deux ans si les choses
se passent pas et je pense qu'il faut
qu'elle avance vous laisser deux ans ça
veut dire en 2020 vous serez vous ferez
quoi je serai à la région j'espère en
forme je cultive ma forme
dans deux ans je souffrais yoga et
méditation tous les matins à 5 heures du
matin et j'invite donc ça vous emmène sa
vous avez une en pleine forme en 2020 en
pleine forme 2020 2021
ça veut dire vent ça ça peut être
éventuellement les les élections
municipales où vous serez candidat de
nouveau je serai je pense que je serai
présent de nouveau bien sûr si je suis
en forme et aucune raison ne soit pas
présent mais après les municipales c'est
dans la foulée elle est partie nationale
et régionale et nationale donc on vous
intéresse le plus dans ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est la bo est ce
que vous pensez que vous serez plus
efficace dont on va présenter moi je
vais être efficace dont je peux aider
mon mouvement mais mais mon équipe avait
traversé gagner
comment mener votre avis ce soir où je
vais en discuter avec mon équipe le jeu
serait là où mon équipe souhaite que je
sois un nom parce que c'est très tôt un
pour l'instant je serais je si on sait
que la campagne commence tôt oui mais
moi je veux bien finir là j'ai des beaux
projets a terminé chant train de me
battre pour les terminer et je pense
qu'avec un bon bilan une bonne équipe
pourra envisager des échéances dans de
bonnes conditions et c'est ce que je
perds mais je serai aussi à penser que
les groupes vous pensez que le parti
socialiste peut reprendre la région oh
je pense qu'il est trop tôt je pense
qu'il faut s'occuper d'abord des
municipales la région viendra en son
temps un mot rapide je sais que ça
mériterait une émission tiers mais sur
la forme constitutionnelle qui va
commencer à être examiné demain en
commission des lois
vous êtes pour la suppression de
l'amendement virapin oui totalement moi
je suis d'accord avec ceux qui ont
présenté une motion un amendement avec
eric a barrel bien sûr bello monsieur
lorient si j'ai lu sa déclaration dans
la presse je ris je crois qu'il faut et
faut arrêter de parler d'un moment il
faut permettre aux réunionnais d'adapter
largement dont cet amendement qui
verrouille et les gens nous ont bien
réduit on peut déjà faire non non non
pas leur boulot il dépend forme
d'honneur
mon propre il devrait tourner la page ça
pour moi je ne discute pas ce qu'il a
fait il ya 30 ans aujourd'hui n'a plus
de raison d'être aujourd'hui le pouvoir
d'adaptation doit être le plus large
possible
or il verrouille l'adaptation sur je
dirais le champ de compétences de l'état
et ça c'est une erreur
les martiniquais et guadeloupéens et
guyane et ont ce pouvoir les réunionnais
doivent l'avoir puisqu'il est soumis
bien sûr à une validation de l'assemblée
donc aucun risque il faut faire sauter
ces d'amendements qui et qui n'a plus de
raison d'être qui est qui est de mise et
spatiaux n'est pas sûr que le
gouvernement vous suivre mais j'espère
qu'ils me suivra parce qu' il serait en
opposition avec ce qu'ils nient le
gouvernement répète qu'il veut que les
territoires et la possibilité d'adapter
pour être efficace donc il faut qu'ils
enlèvent cet amendement qui le remplace
alors je parle pas d'enlever
l'amendement je pense qu'il faut le rock
il remplace en autorisant les
adaptations sur les champs de
compétences des collectivités de cas et
sur le champ de compétences des
compétences de l'état un mot très rapide
je sais que vous êtes un amateur de
football vous suivez la compétition oui
seulement un pronostic je pense que la
france est une équipe pour arriver en
quarts de finale quart de finale suivra
ça on verra ça dans deux minutes
dramatiques pendant les infos et puis
ensuite c'est l'audi qui vous
accompagnera demain matin à 7 heures
c'est didier fauchard le patron du medef
qui sera l'invité de philippe dornier et
puis demain soir il n'y a pas de
l'émission puisque qu'à foot demain soir
justement
bonne soirée à vous